in case you haven't heard about idea the
same source that League entire season
seven has finally got his cents around
some season 8 info the source is freaky
doctor whose channel you can visit by
clicking the links in description down
below last year this guy shared the
entire season 7 plot claiming it's legit
lakes and as most of you know it turned
out to be hundred percent accurate
freaky doctor finally got some more
information regarding the final season
and shared it a couple of days ago it's
about the final plot fest of the series
that will take place in the season 8
finale
it's about Tyrion Lannister whose
intelligence humor and wit made him fans
favorite character however he'll
apparently end as a traitor and who face
the trial at the dragon pit for that
which will result with his death in
details freaky doctor says that in the
charge of a trial ser Davos Seaworth
accompanied with all the Sharks sensory
and brain stark they're also similarly
Brienne of Tarth Robin Arryn and two new
characters one of them wearing a golden
armor grave or medium solid will also be
there with a group of the unsullied
guarding Tyrion Lannister Tyrion is
being on trial for betraying Daniel's
family freaky doctor says that bran
circles his greenside powers during his
trial and take us back to the first
season bran will recall something Tyrion
said to his mother Catelyn Stark in the
first season
it's Tyrion statement that he would
never bet against his family there's
another thing we know they will say they
deserve it
implying that the people of King's
Landing deserve to die Tyrion is full of
anger the most traumatic moment of the
trial will be Tyrion falling on his
knees in the middle of the speech
dragged down by his actions he also will
not be able to ask for a trial by combat
free doctor doesn't know how Taryn will
be executed because unlike the trial his
death wasn't filmed in Seville but in
the studio he also mentions that there
will not be much of a snow at the dragon
pit as most of it already melted down at
this point of the season meaning that
Ventura is most likely over by the time
terrains being under the trial there's
one more info but it's more of a rumor
than allegedly it says that while Tyrion
is being charged Winterfell is being
reconstructed
okay during the Schrader's and is being
judged in the Game of Thrones finale
he's betrayed Danny and his sided with
his family but how is it possible one
might ask well in truth it's all be
happening before our eyes as most of us
who claimed he has done everything he
could to aid in the rise of Danny
Targaryen the Queen he believes can
bring stability to Westeros her cause is
the one he believes in
he tried to keep her from making rash
violent decisions so that she can be
seen as the ruler the realm needs but
he's actually been fighting for the best
for Daenerys has he really been making
decisions that will bring Danny one step
closer towards the throne just the
opposite turns be fighting for house
Lane
throughout the entire season seven and
we've all witnessed it let me explain it
because of Tyrion and his Warplanes Dany
has lost most of our allies and her
strength has drastically decreased due
to Tyrion and his plans Dany has lost
Dorne in the Iron Islands - urine in
Cersei
Tyrion strategy to take Casterly Rock
was a disaster as well the unsullied of
the fortress but the fortress was
severely undermanned as most of Leinster
garrison has led the castle and attacked
Tygart destroying another day is a lion
taking all the food and cold Tyrion was
basically outwitted by his brother Jaime
Lannister it's also worth mentioning
that eel salad left Casterly Rock by the
time all the lords kings and queens met
at the dragon pit making turns plain
once again meaningless the final
proposal Tyrion head for Dany was to
bring the dead to Cersei Lannister to
win her support
he thinks the army of the Dead is
nothing but a story made up by wet
nurses to frighten children what if we
proved her wrong I don't think she'll
come see the dead at my invitation so
bring the dead to her bring one of these
things down to King's Landing and show
her the truth this resulted with the
death of a dragon if it Circe is still
not giving a concern about the White
Walkers all these Terrance plans result
with the food and the goal being
unprotected and basically for Cersei to
take it which she did
turn-ons plans also resulted with an
opportunity for Cersei to wipe out most
of Dana's allies which she also did is
it possible the Tyrians being outsmarted
by Cersei and Jaime even though he's
said to be the smartest Lannister it's a
really cool silence that Tolkien's plans
made more damage than good for Dany
I don't think so and here's why Tyrion
whose weight intellect and keen mind for
strategy was seemingly without peer
ragged Wester sustained his hand with
one of the greatest armies that Westeros
has ever seen if he wanted to turn could
have secured the drum for Dany and make
her arm is stronger than ever but he did
just the opposite and with a purpose to
make his family the most powerful once
again one might ask but could we be
giving too much credit to Tyrion and his
abilities perhaps Tyrion is not so smart
after all and all the plans he made were
not intended to fail and make Dany
weaker while at the same time making
House Lannister stronger one would say
but I highly doubt that's the case this
is our george RR martin the one who
wrote this character had to say about
her and Lannister
so basically Martin had this idea for a
character for one of his books to be the
Lord that had to be the ugliest person
in the world but at the same time the
most intelligent as well this idea
appeared to him and he was writing Game
of Thrones and his character came to
life with
long story short the only way for Cersei
and Jaime to appear as the winning side
against deserts what beef Tyrion was
still fighting for his family if he
decided to spare their lives and
according to the new league's they're
most likely 100% legit that's exactly
the case may still sound ridiculous to
some of you but her some additional
clues that Tyrion has betrayed any
Tyrion prides himself on his ability to
read people as easily as he does books
and has on many occasions easily gotten
better off not just Joffrey and Cersei
but also experienced players such as
Littlefinger did he really believes her
see when she said that she will send
help nor to Ada living in the great for
against night king the answer is no
matter of fact Cersei and Tyrion made
this decision together let me explain
how they took place in the season 7
finale opening moments Johnston was
presented with the opportunity to earn a
promise of peace from Cersei he instead
chooses to remain loyal to Dani during
in particular was upset with Jon
explaining that sometimes there's a
value in telling someone you'll give
them what they want even if you don't
plan on actually in doing so which is
exactly what Orion and Cersei did later
in the episode which starts promising to
aid them in the great war anyway it's a
tense meeting between Cersei and Tyrion
followed but it's what happened off
screen that matters most throughout the
meeting Tyrion even confess that he's
the one preventing health Lannister from
falling difficult working towards the
same goal the calm you've worked towards
your entire family I am no 1 in
preventing that from happening
Daenerys didn't want to debate and
negotiate she didn't want to bring new
words she wanted to bring you fire and
blood until I advised her otherwise I
don't want to destroy our family I never
have which he surely did they told the
war plans he made one knowing they would
fail all that I already explained
earlier in this video
Tyrion is smart and all the plans he
made his soul through them and he saw
the outcome everything he did he did it
with a purpose and that's to prevent
House Lannister from falling to make it
stronger anyways after professing his
love for Cersei disease children and
realizing his sister was pregnant even
Sultan's just before the camera cuts
away from the scene all together the
next time we see two characters sees
during the return to the dragon pit
Cersei suddenly willing to help John and
Danny in their battle against the White
Walkers so to be clear Tyrion said to
read people and their intentions as
easily as he reads books which has been
proven right multiple times throughout
the series but he fails to read through
Cersei he fails to read through search
tension and he believes her she'll send
help Tyrion and Cersei most likely made
a deal in their meeting exactly when the
camera cut away and it's Tyrion who told
Cersei to agree with John and Danny and
to promise them the help in the wars to
come having earlier in his same episode
synturion emphasized the value of a good
lie to Jon Snow it's reasonable to
believe his stress this to his sister
behind closed doors
Tyrion cut a deal with Cersei he know
she wasn't going to go north and he told
her to lie about it even the scene with
Circe reveals her true intention to
Jaime could be seen as the proof that
Tyrion has already betrayed Danny Circe
says so Jaime you were always a dumbass
Lannister who do you do preparing the
expedition knows this is in reference to
him falling for a lie but Tyrion was
also there and is also Lannister if he
fell for a lie as well it would be not
phrase for it to use I feel like her
attitude and phrasing implies that
Tyrion was in don't lie basically Turner
works for the best of his family and the
two most likely be exposed brain in his
visions what we know for certain is that
Tyrion will have a trial for his treason
or Danny and he will die the Sirians
betrayal might have even been foretold
in the prophecy in the books in the
george RR martin novels that inspired
the game of thrones then here's a
prophecy in the house of the undying
that leads her to believe she'll face
three keep trails the prophecy says
three treason civilian no one's for
blood and once for gold and once for
love well this exact prophecy never made
it into the show the betrayal certainly
did in season one murmurs door killed
her unborn son to save Joe's life
this is a treason for blood since Mira
betrayed her in avenge for the attack on
her village and the ritual only returns
jogo to a vegetative state while causing
her son to die in her womb gerrae
betrayed any for gold as he spied on
Danny for King Robert's heart by various
exchange for gold
the only much reason left is the one for
love and that be Tyrion marking the
biggest plot waste of series beside
Anna's love for Tyrion that fulfills
that part of the prophecy then he's also
been warned in the novel A Dance with
Dragons not a trustee on with this
prophecy soon comes the pale mare and
after her the others Kraken and dark
flame Leah and Griffin the sun sun and
the mummer's dragon just none of them
remember the undying
beware of the perfumed seneschal Lion
House Lannister sigil is finally
accepted to be Tyrion Lannister all
these clothes and hints along with the
most reliable source releasing season
eight leagues that claim that Tyrion is
going to be in the season finale under a
trial for treason makes this huge plot
waste almost as earned
thing thus far Tyrion has survived two
trials but this one the third one seems
to be an end of terror Lannister making
the end of Game of Thrones truly
bittersweet my dear brother our time
she'll ever wonder whose side you're on
my dear brother you wound me you know
how much I love my family